mange quand tu auras repris des forces
tu pourras te promener au bout d'eux
semble sur mon domaine mais quand la
nuit sera tombée je t'interdis de sortir
du château
si je dois mourir autant c'est ça la
terre tu as plus de courage que ton père
ce prince qui n'est pas charmant
finalement est un homme qui a tout perdu
à cause de justement de son avidité et
vivre pendant 400 ans enfermé tout seul
recouvert de poils dans un château
abandonné seul avec sa culpabilité
donc c'est un instinct d'hommes qui
pensent qu'il ne peut plus inspiré
l'amour et le jour où une femme croise
son chemin nouveau
il pense que le seul moyen de la garder
près de lui ces deux là dominé de
l'enfermer de l'acheter avec des robes
et des cadeaux donc pour moi il ya une
métaphore assez forte de de l'attitude
masculine machiste et des fois de notre
incapacité à avouer notre notre
vulnérabilité auprès d'une femme mais il
ya évidemment de savoir que c'est une
carte très importante à jouer quand on
veut pécho et qu'est ce que la bête
d'affaires en même temps ton personnage
c'est beaucoup l'amour qui la motive au
début l'amour du père et tout ça pour
son père après évidemment voilà on sait
la bête on la sent physiquement
intellectuellement à tirer c'est ça son
auteur principal c'est l'amour est ce
personnage
oui je pense que oui je pense que c'est
l'amour et puis c'est la découverte du
monde aussi en fait c'est une jeune
femme qui
vierge qui comme ça très attaché à sa
famille et puis qui décide de se
confronter aux dangers et à la vie d'une
certaine façon est en fait c'est aussi
une histoire d'amour la belle et la bête
c'est surtout une histoire d'amour j'ai
besoin de deux heures précises
tu devras gèdre aulas ne pense même pas
déraper la forêt se refermerait or noir